navigating college is no easy task add
law school to the mix and your dreams
may start to feel unreachable especially
if you're alone a big barrier was
getting the materials to study paying
for the tests paying for the reports
monique rodriguez is now on her way to
unlv's boyd school of law she was able
to pay for her admission test prep
courses thanks to an andale scholarship
it's something that can add up to
seventeen hundred dollars when i got
that scholarship i was like all right
now i you know i can move forward with
what i want to do to help more students
the nevada latino bar association is
putting on the third annual andale 5k on
september 18th we have medals this year
we'll have mexican pastries at the end
yes and hopefully we're working on
getting some a mariachi band as well the
5k has been breaking its own records
collecting more cash every year to date
nearly 186 thousand dollars for more
than a hundred students founder and race
director marisa rodriguez tells us why
she's helping others
i didn't go to law school until i was 30
years old and i wanted to go to law
school all my life but i didn't have
anyone she's a senior deputy city
attorney for the city of north las vegas
but fewer than 5 percent of the nation's
attorneys are hispanic while making up
18.5 percent of the population and it's
even worse for latinas we are the most
underrepresented population demographic
with fewer than 2 percent you can
support their mission by registering for
the 5k you can run walk or dance if
you'd like we need to have a seat at the
table
it helps on so many levels hector mejia
reporting 8 news now